#HASHTAGWARS.
KIDS!
YOUR VIDEO GAMES.
E3 STARTED TODAY AND X-BOX ONE
ANNOUNCED THE RELEASES OF A NEW
"HALO: MASTER CHIEF COLLECTION"
AND A NEW TOMB RAIDER, WHICH
FEATURES ALL THE EXCITEMENT OF
LARA CROFT IN THERARPY
>> I THINK WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
IN THESE SESSIONS.
YOU SAY THE THE FLASH BACKS HAVE
STOPPED.
THAT'S EXCELLENT IMPROVEMENT.
( LAUGHTER )
>> I HOPE SHE SORTS OUT HER
ISSUES?
IN THIS GAME.
THESE VIDEO GAMES BRING ME BACK
TO THE 90s, SO IN HONOR OF
THEIR RESURECTIONS, TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS #RUINTHE90S.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
EXAMPLES WOULD BE CLARISSA
EXPLAINS MY BALLS.
OR JUST SINGLED OUT. ( BLEEP )
IT.
YEAH.
NICOLAS CAGE AGAINST THE
MACHINE.
ANYTHING FROM THE 90s.
BULLS ON PARADE.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND GO.
STEVE AGEE.
>> BOY MEETS WORLD STAR HIP-HOP.
>> POINTS.
MICHELLE.
>> FRESH PUBES OF HAIR.
>> YES, POINTS.
STEVE.
>> BILLY CRYSTAL PEPSI.
>> OH, CRYSTAL PEPSI.
THAT ALREADY RUINED THE 90s.
POINTS.
MICHELLE.
>> LOST THE BABY SPICE.
>> DAVE HILL.
>> LA-LA CHLAMYDIA.
>> POINTS.
MICHELLE.
>> SALT AND POOPERS HERE.
>> POINTS. AH, PUSH IT.
STEVE.
>> CHODE THE WET SPROCKET.
>> YEAH, CHODE THE WET
SPROCKET, SURE, POINTS. DAVE.
>> OKAY LOOKING WOMAN.
( LAUGHTER )
>> OH, YES, SURE.
YES.
( APPLAUSE )
>> NO, NO, COME BACK!
IT'S NOT OVER, STEVE.
>> HOLE.